ils étaient des centaines aujourd'hui a
lancé une initiative pour freiner les
changements climatiques la population
voue à la maison vous êtes invités à
signer un document intitulé le pacte
pour la transition et à l'instant on me
disait qu'il y avait déjà treize mille
429 signature sur le site le pacte point
c est par ce pacte les québécois
s'engage à poser des gestes concrets
pour sauver la planète parfois ce soit
de petits gestes un des instigateurs
dont l'instigateur le metteur en scène
dominic champagne
bonsoir de champagne soit il va
reconnaît votre engagement l'on va
entendre quelqu'un qui était là ce matin
est ce qu'il faisait un meilleur culpa
on écoute nous reste et auteur l'immense
y est c'est ok qui suis-je pour aller
dire aux autres commun se comporter
comment vivre je plein d'incohérences
môme il ya plein de choses que je suis
d'accord je regarde les études chez nous
je fais comme est épouvantable je fais
pas grand chose je représente est
exactement le problème c'est à dire
legault de banlieue de 45 ans qui a des
enfants que pas le choix d'avoir un choc
non je suis pas parfait par contre je
m'engage à une chose regardez mon mode
de vie présentement pas dit comment je
pourrais faire les choses différemment
à partir d'aujourd'hui est une prise de
conservation de notre championnat alors
c'est un bel exemple de prise de
conscience dont on peut penser qu'il
parle de son char je veux parler de sa
voiture ou son choix il va peut-être
changer de chars prennent électrique ans
et j'avais donc c'est un exemple de
prise de conscience
well et parce que ce que louis
morissette exprime en fait c'est que il
oui j'ai sollicité des signatures à pour
répondre à l'appel du secrétaire général
des nations unies qui dit il faut que
les sociétés civiles sans même parce
qu'on a deux ans pour agir
auquel cas les conséquences risquent
d'être désastreuse
visiblement ils voient venir que la
difficulté des gouvernements de remplir
leur et les engagements qu'ils ont pris
à paris il ya trois ans alors faisant
appel à la société civile moi je me dis
ben c'est nous la société civile les
artistes sur des bon relayeur des bons
transmetteur ils ont des hauts parleurs
des micros des haut parleurs
alors je suis allé rencontrer des
sommités scientifiques catherine pas de
vin une autorité en matière de
réchauffement climatique au canada qui a
rien fait des travaux avec plusieurs des
plusieurs dizaines ou en centaines de
scientifiques récemment normand mousseau
qui a présidé la commission sur
l'énergie au québec et avec quelques
bonnes plumes
on a rédigé ce pacte où on se dit ben
nous on va plutôt que de pointer
strictement le mauvais gouvernement ou
les actions difficiles du gouvernement
on va dire au faire notre part ayant un
certain nombre de gestes que réellement
on peut poser c'est à dire que tous les
matins montréal ya encore énormément des
taux mobilis qui s'en vont travailler
seul dans la voiture sont pris dans la
congestion
alors déjà on pourrait réduire de moitié
l'empreinte si tout le monde voyager à
deux par voiture dont il ya dix avant
qu'on embarque dans la ligne rose le je
pense qu'un certain nombre de gestes
proposés
oui alors l'alimentation la
consommation' voilà à l'aube en fait on
fait la nomenclature et ça amène des
réflexions comme celle de louis
morissette qui dit avec de quel droit
moi aujourd'hui je dis là je vais en
application puisque mon comportement et
pas est pas exemplaire mais on est tous
intoxiquées dans cette civilisation du
pétrole on est tous
j'en veux dire qu'on plie complice dans
le crime mais la raison scientifique
nous dit il faut agir c'est urgent le
dernier rapport du giec il nous apprend
pas grand chose de plus sinon que les
scientifiques ont appuyé sur le bouton
panique il faut réagir il ya une urgence
et les canadiens on est parmi les pires
au monde sadique notre niveau
vie notre mode de vie exigerait trois ou
quatre planètes au niveau des réserves
en même temps le giec je crois nous dit
aussi que c'est au canada qui aura un
très très grand impact avec l'arctique
qui font la montée désolation non on a
je pense qu'on est dans une situation
individuellement ou je peux dire c'est
facile de faire de faire déposer des
gestes mais assurément on peut donc le
pack qui propose quoi on posons des
gestes individuels
sachant très bien que la somme de nos
gestes nos gestes individuels ne suffira
pas et que ça prend aussi des grandes
politiques mais plutôt que de
strictement pointe et l'autre du doigt
du doigt leur ont dit on va faire notre
effort mais delebarre le pacs a joué à
deux donc aussi des exigences clairement
posée à nos gouvernements pour qu'ils
aient un éloignement du pétrole
notamment dans les transports
notre premier ministre legault la
démocratie vient de parler au québec et
on est élu un gouvernement qui était
dernier de classe dans sa plateforme
environnementale et le premier ministre
au premier jour de son mandat dit nous
avons entendu le message la population
et on va tenir compte
alors nous on voit le juge si l'on
répond à l'appel du secrétaire général
des nations unies envoie propose un bac
allons chercher un million de signatures
pour que la société civile fasse
contrepoids dès l'aube est souvent
extrêmement puissant qui impose des
décisions ont levé avec monsieur trudeau
qui s'est fait élire sur la base de
promesses lui allait couper les
subventions aux industries pétrolière et
qui nous nous enfoncent dans quelques
jours milliards de dollars dans le fait
qu'ils se ce dont parle monsieur trudeau
en revanche c'est de dire défaut vivent
une sorte de transition aura encore une
dépendance au pétrole
ce sont des emplois ce sont des
questions politiques n'y a pas que le
canada qui pensent de cette manière là
et d'ailleurs cela dit ce qu'on a
entendu parler pour la première fois de
ce que vous avez annoncé et si un
perroquet un 10-0 effectivement continue
de s'enfoncer dans le pétrole alors que
le québec est extrêmement bien dotées
parce qu'on a fondé notre modernité
énergétique sur deux valeurs
fondamentales je pense que l'important
aujourd'hui de se rappeler le partage
des richesses et une énergie
renouvelable propre
alors je pense que croire en nous mêmes
c'est opérer la transition est allé dans
le sens de ce que la raison scientifique
nous demande et je pense que cela
devrait peser plus lourd dans la balance
que les intérêts des lobbys très puisse
vous vous consacrez parce qu'entièrement
celle que vous avez fait
des spectacles dans le passé dont
j'oublie le nom moment je vous parle
mais pourquoi c'est devenu votre cause
et vous êtes un metteur en scène noire
ans et je pense si souvent cette idée
que mon grand père est né dans un monde
où on peut boire loi même leur bissau et
moi je vais légué en héritage à mes fils
un monde où on assiste présentement on
est des on est les contemporains de
l'effondrement de la vie sur terre
nouvelle la semaine dernière 60 % des
espèces animales ont disparu aux animaux
les animaux depuis 40 ans on est les
contemporains de sens et la raison
la raison c'est pas de l'idéologie c'est
l'effet a menée par des scientifiques
nous dit il faut s'éloigner du pétrole
pour se rapprocher du bonheur commun et
de la protection du monde dans lequel on
vit
c'est pour rien alors pour moi c'est
difficile en image et de la difficulté à
me dire je vais aller faire tourner des
ballons sur mon nez à montréal ou en
chine pendant que ça se passe alors je
faisais il faut qu'il en est une qu'il
fasse beau lob juste à montaut mais
quand elle chantait l'hymne à la beauté
du monde va le faire à une jeune poète
7,6 maurice la tête jacques cartier en
1972 c'est une des plus belles chansons
de documents dont part j'en suis pas là
je ne suis pas m'immoler encore mais je
pense qu'on peut collectivement alors se
reprendre confiance en nous mêmes en
posant des gestes collectif ça doit
commencer avec vos enfants elle la
tentation de la surconsommation sur les
enfants il est là aussi les gadgets
électroniques tout ce qui tout ce qui
nous est proposé dans ce modèle
consommateurs et je peux dire que s'il
ya une chose que j'admire que mes
garçons c'est leur tendance naturelle à
la sobriété probablement en réaction à
ce que leur père était mais c'est
quelque chose qui est admirable chez mes
fils c'est que ils trouvent leur bonheur
ailleurs que dans la possession la
consommation
et ma foi je me sens vraiment devoir de
soutenir dans cette voie là parce qu'on
a eu des versions absolument urgente et
nécessaire au pays
avez vous un exemple à nous donner de
vos efforts avoue personnel je circule
beaucoup en vélo je travaille en vélo à
montréal là j'ai décidé depuis un mois
ou deux de réduire ma consommation
devient alors aussi sauter un
cheeseburger ou un steak tartare sur
deux on dit qu'il ya un impact quand
même important de la culture de la
viande rouge notamment
alors je pense qu'une série de gestes
jeunes voitures électriques dont j'ai
gagné le jackpot à las vegas j'ai
moyennement pays
je dis pas que c'est la panacée mais il
reste qu'il ya un virage et tout le
monde est convié c'est pas une affaire
de riches ou de pauvres bien sûr les
gens plus démunis ont des idées ont des
difficultés plus grandes que que
quelqu'un comme moi qui je peux chercher
un privilégié de la société mais je
pense pas que ça appartient strictement
à ceux qui ont plus de moyens je pense
que tout le monde doit faire son effort
à commencer par les politiques publiques
il est la grande industrie qui ont un
impact extrêmement important alors on va
suivre de près l'évolution de ceux de ce
pacte son attrait le pack point ca merci
dominique champagne
merci et bonne chance merci